most people probably have some idea of
what afghanistan is like especially for
women
unfortunately our country hasn't known
peace for a long time and whilst it has
never been particularly safe for girls
like my sisters and i since the early
2000s
women have experienced great
improvements with their rights and
freedoms especially in cities like kabul
where we lived
all four of us graduated with our
bachelor's degrees here in common and
some of us even went on to get a
master's degree
we all learned how to drive owned our
own cars to drive to our dream jobs we
owned property in carbon and weren't
required to dress in a specific way
living in afghanistan always brings some
risk for example in 2017 a bomb exploded
in my sister's office building and a
couple of years later another one went
off outside the cinema that we were in
whilst it's not the battlefield some
people might be picturing
the threat of violence was ever present
in more rural areas of the country
fighting was fierce and many people were
wounded and died from homemade mines in
fields and villages
during the summer of 2021 everything
changed for women in afghanistan the u.s
were planning on removing all of their
troops by september 11th and it quickly
became clear that the leadership in our
country was about to change women like
my sisters and i started buying head
coverings such as hijab keeping them in
our purses in case the taliban entered
our cities and we had to make a quick
escape to safety
a few days before the taliban entered
kabul
my sister and i started getting more
warnings from the security guards at our
jobs
we both worked for international
organizations so it was information we
felt we could rely on
the city was on the verge of being taken
and the reality started hitting us
we weren't safe and we needed a plan to
get out as free single women that work
for international organizations we
feared for our liberty and our lives as
we would be potential targets
over the next two days our sole focus
was to withdraw our life savings from
the bank and find our way onto an
evacuation list however when we went to
the bank the first day we quickly
realized we weren't the only ones with
this idea
when we returned the following day at
six am there were even more people there
that day we got the news
the taliban had entered kabul
panic
female bank employees fled businesses
closed their doors traffic jams
everywhere we needed to go home
immediately
we were told that the taliban were in
our neighborhood going door to door
checking who lived there
change of plans we headed to our
sister's house instead she was married
and had a child we would be safer there
i even hid my international journalist
id card in my shoe in case we got
stopped by the taliban on our way there
over the next couple of days we rarely
left the house women now required males
escorting them outside and were no
longer going to their offices banks were
closed and our only priority was to
evacuate
we were reaching out to all our
international contacts to get ourselves
onto an evacuation plane
on the 18th one of my former colleagues
in italy managed to get my sisters and i
on an evacuation list it would mean my
sister eight months pregnant would have
to leave her husband the father of her
unborn child behind
we would also be leaving our father
behind as well as our properties cars
and 99 of our belongings
i was begging my sisters to go
reassuring them that i would stay and
look after our dad but in the end it was
him that pushed us all to take this
opportunity for safety
even though we made it onto an
evacuation list we still had to find a
way into the airport
entrance gates had multiple taliban
checkpoints and thousands of people were
trying to get through violence
inevitably broke out
people were losing their lives
and international forces had to close
the gates
fortunately on the second day our
italian contacts sent us the location of
another gate luckily there were fewer
crowds and no taliban checkpoints this
time
we are outside in the sun for more than
10 hours talking to different
international forces waiting to make
contact with our italian security guards
finally we were let inside
that night we boarded the italian
military evacuation we were cold and
exhausted
but on our way to safety together
when we landed in italy we received a
lot of support from the italian
government we were provided with
accommodation language classes and even
some pocket money since we still didn't
have access to our life savings
we had successful lives in afghanistan
we were in our dream jobs we had
financial stability and independence
now we are faced with the prospect of
starting from scratch all over again
what will our future look like
will we always feel different
isolated
alone
however we have been very fortunate
compared to the asylum seekers from
other countries
we didn't need to enter the eu illegally
through expensive human spoilers or long
journeys that can be especially
dangerous for women
our language teacher and our housemates
have been very friendly and supportive
but it's going to take time to integrate
and become fluent
we have a new addition to the family now
our father and brother-in-law also
managed to join us in italy and the
government is helping us to find
accommodation so that our family can
live under the same roof
this was our story a true story coming
from a big city being educated owning
property getting on an evacuation list
we were the fortunate ones men women and
children from rural parts of afghanistan
rarely have such opportunities
next time you see or hear of asylum
seekers perhaps you'll remember our
story we don't ask for pity just
understanding
you